on en parlait tout à l'heure il est
sérieux comme tout non j'écoute beaucoup
moi j'ai lu le livre
il y a quelques temps j'ai ça m'a
beaucoup touché j'aime beaucoup écouter
ces voilà c'est c'est touchant c'est
vrai ce qu'il dit et c'est comme ça je
connais Mario donc voilà je sais des
fois écouter et évidemment voilà
évidemment allez la star avec on va voir
parler on va prendre de vos nouvelles
qu'est-ce que vous êtes devenus de cul
alors on va voir vous savez on vous a vu
depuis 20 ans de star Acer écoutez
c'était ça
[Musique]
le plus gros tubes de la Star
Academy à ce jour
de single ça fait plus de 5 millions de
disques
et moi comme téléspectrice je crois que
j'ai adoré franchement tu t'es régalé
grave j'adorais la Star Ac c'était
génial enfin bon c'était nouveau c'était
c'était notre réalisateur aujourd'hui a
réalisé des musiques c'est incroyable à
réaliser
mon livre dans une librairie la semaine
dernière et il y a une dame qui vient me
voir qui me disait mon père pour me
punir
je te priverais de Star Ac tu sais pas
tu es un carton
il y avait pas beaucoup de chaînes de
télé forcément la finale c'est encore
parti des top 3 records je crois des
audiences de TF1
tu te retrouves à la sarraque vous lui
demandez aussi
j'ai vu ce spot pub à la télé j'ai
envoyé un message vocal je crois sur un
répondeur tout simplement
et puis on m'a demandé une cassette
vidéo VHS me filmer et puis d'audition
audition je suis tombé voilà je suis
arrivé dans les je sais pas il y avait
50000 personnes à la fin 50 on a fini à
100 sur le plateau puis 50 25 et puis le
16 c'est enfin quand j'en parle
aujourd'hui encore je dis c'est assez
incroyable c'était la chance de ma vie
je l'avoue aujourd'hui moi j'avais la
vie avant la Star Ac et ma vie
aujourd'hui
sauvage on m'a dit bonjour Est-ce que tu
veux chanter j'ai dit non je me suis
retrouvé là voilà pour la faire très
court on m'a dit vas-y venez de finir
mes études j'avais loupé mon BTS je les
pompiers en plage et puis j'ai dit bon
je vais profiter encore 15 jours avant
de rentrer dans le monde du travail
c'est ça et je ne suis jamais rentré
dans le monde du travail et d'ailleurs
une autre anecdote parce que ça a parlé
en coulisse de nous pendant les
auditions il y avait Pascal comme
vous étiez mignon à l'époque
mais vous me dites toujours mais
regardez pour nous c'est on le disait
tout à l'heure mais franchement on a pas
trop mal non mais pas du tout
Mario depuis la musique mais la musique
j'ai arrêté juste après le décès de mon
papa voilà en 2010 et puis j'ai fait
j'ai investi dans les affaires et
aujourd'hui j'ai deux entreprises qui
fonctionnent très bien et avec réflexion
aujourd'hui j'ai bien fait d'arrêter à
cette époque là il y avait la clé du
disque le disque marchait moins bien les
spectacles vont plus tard et voilà donc
aujourd'hui j'ai fait mon livre et je
pense que je vais refaire un album
parce que c'était pas mal avec Jennifer
à l'époque
c'est
[Musique]
elle pleure Jennifer c'est quoi là 22
ans
pour moi de
l'élection
finale c'est là où elle t'avait promis
la fin
[Rires]
avec ça
elle avait dit si je gagne
Mario adore ses voitures et ben il est
là
j'ai perdu un pari et il m'a offert une
belle montre exactement si si je dirais
pas la marque c'est une belle montre de
marque et je lui rappelle je lui dis
c'est mon fils mon grand garçon qui l'a
aujourd'hui et Jennifer vous avez encore
des contacts Jean-Pascal
on s'est vu au 20 ans on s'est vu au 20
ans de la de loin voilà ils sont venus
dedans on n'a pas été très chaleureuse
avec vous on s'est vite vu OK
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le téléphone est interdit au château
nous avions tous une minute de téléphone
moi avec mon grand cœur Jessica qui
était assez triste je lui donner ma
minute régulièrement et Mario
pas les résultats non il a jamais
partagé
5 minutes en espérant rentabiliser après
un investissement
les déguisements les les enfin on peut
pas le dire mais petite anecdote c'était
l'anniversaire de Mario et nous en fait
venir des petites danseuses assez sympa
elle était autorisé ils ont fait évacuer
le château ah oui bien sûr tout couper
on va profiter un peu c'est les caméras
c'était super c'était une soirée c'est
une soirée en boîte les gens c'est là où
ils ont les jeunes filles étaient
sympathiques et accueillantes très
fraîches
bon on va recadrer les choses c'est une
école parce qu'on avait de quoi faire la
fête un peu bien sûr et ben il y avait
plus rien il y avait plus d'alcool plus
de soirée et tout c'est là où on a
commencé à dire ça va être un peu long
peut-être
aujourd'hui impossible un truc pareil
c'est impossible d'ailleurs je regrette
un peu ce travail parce qu'aujourd'hui
tout est impossible c'est dommage parce
que il y a quand même je trouve qu'il
faut trouver une mesure
sur quoi
sur plein de choses sur la rigolade sur
l'humour qu'on avait sur la liberté
parce que on n'était pas méchant on est
on se parlait tout à fait comme on se
parle comme ça en train de boire un coup
autour d'une table aujourd'hui on
devrait on aurait enfin moi aujourd'hui
je serai incapable de participer à ce
genre d'émission il y aurait des billes
partout ah oui avec les réseaux sociaux
qui existaient pas à l'époque et puis
aujourd'hui on est quand même un peu
quand même
on a perdu ce naturel et quand on sort
de la Star Ac et qu'il y a 13 millions
téléspectateurs tous les soirs qui vous
adorent qui vous kiffe on prend pas un
peu le Boulard en sortant parce que
c'est pas un peu compliqué suis-je
l'avoue moi on pète un peu les plombs
gentiment gentiment mais on est on avait
des guerres du corps en permanence
pendant deux ou trois ou quatre ans pour
certains on chantait tous les soirs au
zénith deux fois merci trois fois
l'Olympia enfin on vit comme des
Rockstar c'était on était on n'est pas
réparé à ça
vous étiez jeune aucune distance par
rapport à la célébrité à l'argent qui
arrive comme ça je le dis toujours moi
j'ai tout j'ai tout cramé tu as tout
cramé mais tout tu arrives à Paris tu as
23 ans mais toi
mais les voitures tu vas t'acheter des
montres de luxe parce qu'à la télé je
les voyais tous avec des jolies Montréal
aussi ça va très vite quand tu es jeune
comme ça tu penses pas investir comme
les vrais Rockstar donc on a les à la
montagne là où il faut aller on a eu sur
la Côte d'Azur et non c'est génial
combien de temps à peu près quelques
années quoi
le audio
footballeur
on voit très bien après il a eu
l'intelligence d'accepter la proposition
de téléphone de devenir comédien dans
Section de Recherche et là il a fait ses
classes
pour lui dire Jean-Pascal on se connait
pas bien mais je peux te dire comme ça
non non mais c'est vrai exact exact dans
un section de recherche non je veux
juste savoir l'argent combien on peut le
dire 20 ans je le dis toujours 300000
j'ai pas gagné beaucoup mais malgré les
jeux dû prendre 300000 balles mais il
faut enlever les impôts donc c'est une
belle somme et tu enlèves la moitié ça
va très vite
300 voitures 150000 €. ouais 180000 €
net mais ça va à Paris ça va vite tu
achètes une voiture
les Ferrari et les vacances Laurent
Voulzy là c'est super faut pas dire le
nom voilà mais tu vis tu fais pitié
regrouper surtout on faisait plaisir aux
copains parce que c'est vrai en tout cas
pour ma part on avait toujours plein de
monde autour de nous des amis des faux
amis et cetera surtout les faux amis on
en a plus aujourd'hui
on a rendu des gens heureux oui alors
mais ça c'est génial ça c'était super et
la famille elle vous disait pas et les
gars doucement là placez votre acheter
un petit peu
oui mais les parents
merci mais ma mère quand je lui ai dit
ce que j'ai dépensé à Courchevel 6 jours
avec deux de mes amis j'ai eu honte elle
voulait me gifler
pour être dans les Pyrénées
c'était cool puis ça ça me paraît être
on a bossé toi tu as continué certains
trucs moi j'ai fait de la fiction j'ai
fait de l'animation télé parce que quand
on passe de la Ferrari pardon on a parlé
de ça ou de Lamborghini ou je sais pas
on est de la chance parmi d'autres
candidats qui sortaient et qui eux se
retrouvaient vraiment tout sur la rue ça
c'est très compliqué nous on a eu de la
chance j'avais un contrat Universal
pendant plusieurs années j'ai vécu de la
musique moi pendant 10 ans après la Star
Ac et j'ai décidé d'arrêter aujourd'hui
on en a de notre promo dont on n'ira pas
le nom ils sont ils sont très loin ils
ont été psychologiquement ils sont ils
sont foutus
c'est ça qui est donc il faut en fait il
faut profiter sans s'y accrocher et puis
quand ça s'arrête donc on fait autre
chose moi je fais de la télé à télé a
pas été je travaille dans un resto
maintenant je fais partie de l'équipe
ici je suis le plus heureux du monde
Cyril et génial l'équipe est top la vie
va bien et on a monté on a des trois
enfants chacun se dire que si vous vous
donnez pas les moyens et que si vous ne
travaillez pas il n'y a pas de miracle
alors vous êtes allé rencontrer des
candidats justement parce que la star
acade ça reprend en novembre 4 novembre
voilà le 4 novembre et vous avez
rencontré ces candidats là voilà c'est
ces petits jeunes vous êtes allés au
château l'année dernière vous étiez au
château et vous ils vous pose ce genre
de question ou pas du tout enfin comment
on gère quand on sort est-ce que vous
donnez des conseils attention en fait
trop de conseils à donner parce
qu'aujourd'hui avec les réseaux sociaux
avec les réseaux elle est géniale
c'était l'année dernière ça on est
d'ailleurs on peut le dire on est fier
d'avoir été les seuls à aller au château
bien sûr puisque après ils ont arrêté
parce qu'apparemment on a eu trop de
conneries et je sais pas c'est c'est ce
qui paraît mais c'était génial non mais
d'abord de revoir le château c'est
incroyable incroyable et puis moi le
jaune j'ai trouvé sympa les gens de
l'année dernière j'ai trouvé sympa après
c'est compliqué une émission de la Star
Ac qui a eu un engouement à notre époque
incroyable
de pouvoir refaire
et puis là on voit qu'ils vont sortir
des disques maintenant certains de
l'année dernière moi c'est ce que je
comprends pas parce qu'il faut battre le
fer qu'on leur a dit tant qu'il est
chaud mais oui c'est pas méchant ce que
je vais dire mais je pense qu'il y en a
beaucoup qui ont oublié et qui vont
parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est génération
Instagram quoi on tourne la page donc
c'est compliqué il faut il faut y aller
de suite et je pense que c'est j'espère
pas pour eux mais là c'est peut-être un
peu tard pour sortir des disques
maintenant donc ça on les a oublié c'est
un peu ça l'idée ils sont malades il
faut battre le problème c'est là mais ça
ça a toujours été peut-être qu'il va y
avoir une promo derrière non en tout cas
je suis très heureux d'avoir fait
d'avoir connu cette époque ordinaire
parce que trois quatre ans après c'était
terminé c'est-à-dire que on a vraiment
été les derniers d'une génération
des premiers et les derniers les
premiers et les derniers exactement
incroyable donc c'est incroyable et là
ça refaire moi je refais demain de suite
c'était une autre époque voilà il y a
Alexia elle était sur splato il y a il y
a 2 semaines là regarde les souvenirs
la directrice emblématique bien sûr une
question du du PAF que nous avons
sélectionné vous savez sur les réseaux
sociaux vous pouvez envoyer des
questions David vous demande si on vous
proposait un rôle dans la nouvelle
saison de la Star Academy ce que vous
seriez partant je pose la question à
tous les deux
ben moi alors on me l'a proposé mais le
problème c'est comme je suis ici moi TF1
ah oui c'est très simple donc j'ai dit à
TF1 c'est pas vous qui m'avez tendu la
main quand j'ai besoin de repartir à la
télé c'est Cyril donc si vous voulez
voilà c'est ce genre là je suis très
heureux ici sinon ça aurait été oui mais
je suis très bien ici voilà oui pourquoi
pas dans le principe après le problème
c'est que moi j'ai aussi une vie
professionnelle et c'est compliqué de
partir une semaine une semaine et quand
tu changes pas toi
il fait des repas tous les midis
que j'habite à Beaune en Côte d'Ivoire
à consommer avec modération
donc aujourd'hui Mario si on écoute
Jean-Pascal
mais même pas pour être prof mais
peut-être pour leur dire attention ça
dehors faites attention ça faites
peut-être ça pour les guider peut-être
un peu sur la grand frère quoi voilà
parce que je me vois pas prof de chant
et Mario prof de danse non plus donc je
vois pas trop encore à la cuisine ah non
mais prof de chant pourquoi pas sortir
un album mario c'est pourquoi
non attends
prof de chant c'est compliqué